what are the topics that seems to always
come up with every single show is
someone asking who's the greatest chess
player of all time and it makes sense
because everybody always wants to know
who's the best
can we really answer this question no
but we can definitely ask it after right
greatest of all times I mean it's
impossible to compare because of the
generation gaps and the idea is that
chess is making progress every decade
every decade every decade chess advances
and our understanding of in games are
openings our understanding that certain
positions are playable that we didn't
know in the past were playable the
players today really stand on the
shoulders of giants and essentially yeah
they're the best players the world has
ever seen but the question is who's the
greatest of all time and we all have our
personal favors okay come on Maurice you
and I you know we grew up in the United
States I mean bobby fischer's re-watch
buckling style straight out of Brooklyn
he could hang with us in BK any day wait
a minute Bobby Brooklyn come on yeah
that's true there you go so I sit there
and I go for me personally watching what
Anatoly Karpov did Anatoly Karpov had a
chip on his shoulder he won the world
championship title by forfeit so he was
constantly standing in the shadow Bobby
Fischer yeah yeah yeah that was a good
that you just had
Talya but you're no Bobby Fischer I'm
gonna go out and win another tournament
and so Anatoly had like one of the
greatest 10-year periods of any world
champion ever
he just won everything just everything
world championships everything
everything everything and you go oh wow
that guy was really really good and then
you thought at a certain moment well
Anatoly Karpov will never be beaten the
guy loses
one game a year Maurice one gave me here
two games here the top stop stops along
comes this force of nature Garry
Kasparov Garry Kasparov holy cow
he becomes the world's number one player
plays five world champion just quit
Anatoly Karpov that big matches this
series of worlds just punching each
other in the face exactly and in the end
being this far apart in their scores
right but gary keeps the keeps number
one number one rating for twenty years
how can he not be the greatest player
ever and then Garry at really the height
of his powers the year 2000 if the world
is stunned he loses to his protege
Vladimir Kramnik
who goes on and also has quite a
remarkably successful career so the
greatest of all times well obviously
it's Magnus Carlsen because this is the
argument he's and he's making a hell of
an argument Maurice now is this
something of a recency bias because we
have mentioned people who are within the
window of our generation right if you
will and we need to argue for players
like a Morphy great players like
capablanca i mean natural geniuses that
basically didn't even study chess the
Moose's magically came out of their
fingertips exactly but the problem is
when you go back to the Immanuel
Lasker's and the Kappa Blancas and the
Alexander Alekhine
of the world you realize that that was a
space and time when they weren't really
professionals I mean they played one two
tournaments a year I mean certainly they
derived incomes from their professions
but for kappa blanka he was really an
ambassador of cuba that was really what
he achieved was this certainty of having
a steady paycheck by being the
ambassador of cuba being world champion
really really hidden miss and that was
so obvious when the world war two's came
along those wars dis disrupted
everything and it was only after World
War two that the feed a the World Chess
Federation really started sanctioning
the World Championship match cycle and
saying you have to play this Challenger
so for example Alexander Alekhine he
dies whilst well being the world
champion and the feed a convenes and
they approve emotion that recognizes Max
irva as the world champion that was
approved really a feat not aware of yeah
Vijay proved that max irva was declared
world champion end of story 24 hours
later the Soviet delegation arrives at
the feed a meeting and they said look
little we missed our flight we did this
we do it the can we reopen this
discussion as to who the world champion
is and that was where a pro was born but
it and it was max irva saying fair
enough I don't want you to declare me
world champion from Holland right then
you go back and you study some of the
games I will tell you that guy vasily
smyslov was amazing go look it's me
Slavs best games the guy played
everything he really did he played efore
d4 Knight f3 g3 everything he won is
what everything you want is black and
the the guy's attitude was when he's
black you play 40 good moves as white
you got your draw good luck with that
that's Elise me sloth was he was in a
marvelous world champion who was way
over shadowed by Michael bought Vinick
who kept the title for so many years and
then what you said the force of nature
I've ecomod IV Michael tall and his
combinations he just lit the world on
fire it's just amazing yes all the
champions brought something to chess but
certainly the are
now is Magnus going to be considered the
best of all time it's impossible for him
to say it I mean I guess he could just
say it right he's crushing everybody
right he said it looks like he's at the
77th tournament wins winning tournament
after tournament after tournament right
what will he need to do in order to make
the world say this guy is ahead even of
Kasparov and Fischer basically what
Magnus has to do is keep doing what
Magnus is doing and yeah he's gonna have
that title because for me the 20 years
20 years you know how competitive is
chess Oh
so brutal and once you get to the top
how tough it is to beat and maintain and
hold that championship Gary Kasparov
does is for 20 years he's world's number
one playing for 20 years may not be
world champion that whole 20 year but
number one 15 of those years he was the
world champion and there you go and now
you've got Magnus being world world's
number one from what are we gonna say
2010 or there abouts so and he's right
at his peak right now he's won seven
tournaments in a row he's - he's played
for World Championship matches won then
if he maintains and does what he's been
doing for the next 3-4 World
Championship my cycles so you're saying
another eight years you need to see
another eight years even if he breaks
2900 and goes up in the 2950 but that's
not gonna satisfy you separates himself
right now he's way head and shoulders
yeah ahead of the other players even
that's not enough you had to play in a
tournament maybe I'm still carrying the
scars a recency bias you'd say yeah
those scars are still flesh there was
two tournaments in the world and I think
it's fee it's beginning to feel that way
there were two types of
tournaments of the world when I was
playing those that featured Garry
Kasparov and those that didn't that was
it
okay now when Magnus Carlsen pulled sits
down and plays in the same field cup the
Hat Singh field cup feels a lot more
electric when Magnus is here when he's
not and I think that they're also more
wins more excellent play at least from
the players because they're inspired by
the presence of of Magnus Carlsen and
you feel like there's an order in the
chess world with isn't in the tournament
indeed there is a kind of order I don't
know if it inspires the victories or
losses it definitely is inspiring you
know that on Thursday next Thursday you
get to play Magnus Carlsen and the whole
world the spotlight is on your board
because you'll be up against the world's
best player I think that definitely
brings out the fighting spirit that it's
a thorough it's it's very hard to
capture but I have to say when Garry
Kasparov was at his primal best that I
mean he was like a caged beast you know
this was a monster player and what he
did was Fischer asked he would run up
scores like you just said no no no
that's like that's impossible and Gary's
telling me about one particular GMA
event that he won in France where he
gave me a score and I go nah you didn't
do that he said but yes sir I lost the
kid who it was like he was like +9 I
mean and Magnus is getting there trust
me but if he holds that world title and
that's so important to everything right
because that's pivotal that's what your
whole career is going to be measured
against and he wins more grand chess
tours and dominates games with
tournaments like he's been doing he's
gonna is gonna win that title the
argument continues the greatest ever
lots of people who'll be debating that
one it's like Michael or LeBron yeah
it up in chess but for sure we know we
have had some great chess champions no
question